who did this Cushman invented by Edwin
more 1900 know now who who put their DJ
fire up next to my DJ fire that's Ezra's
he's the new IT guy as well yeah amazing
really cool it's a great name
come on what is it my computer keeps
jamming up oh I'll buzz Ezra Oh perfect
yeah yeah hmm hmm I got this it's cool
you don't need your precious as growth
you just you made it worse just gonna
take a second
nah it's okay guys guys Ezra's coming
good I'm glad is then you guys to see me
do this
you missed terribly
you guys didn't want to go you could
have just told me no no we're totally
going we're going we're going together
we're stoked Ezra oh hey you must be
Harper it's nice to finally meet you
I've heard a lot I just speak with you
privately
Ezra sure I'm just doing my ears look I
don't know what you're playing at here
but this this is my turf okay and those
guys those are my idiots look I'm sorry
I did so if I see one more flyer for a
clue thing or hear a new song that you
play for them from someone they've never
heard of before things are gonna get
really painful here Ezra look I just
thought that that's where people post
fliers some people post fliers there
well I'm really excited to see you play
what's your first song gonna be I
usually start with welcome to the jungle
oh that's cute it's ironic yeah sure in
a way no it works it gets the pay I'm
really sorry I hope my enthusiasm didn't
get the best of me it's kind of good
time I stole a parking spot from Lance
Butte oh you know what you probably
don't know who that is
I can see everything you type
welcome to the jungle
you